Hey, Vsauce. Michael here.
And the Internet is a big place.
So, let's take a safari through the World
Wide Web and find some cool things to Do Online
Now Guys.
Size it up with iruler.net.
This website detects your monitor size and
resolution and renders an accurate ruler right
there on your screen.
If you'd rather brake the rules, freak people
out by sending them totally normal links made shady.
You see, instead of shortening links, like
most people like to do, this website makes
URLs look worse.
"5z8.info/hookers_how2printmoney"?
Seems legit.
Lovemonkeysw gave us a site where you can
build a fake Google result page.
So, for instance, I could have it search for
"Anne Hathaway's Secret Crush," and generate
a pic where Google responds "Do you mean Michael
Stevens."
Act even more strategically in Ice Breaker.
Plan ahead and cut carefully as you let chunks
of ice loose, not too big, mind you, for your
friend to break apart.
Exit Path is a beautiful game where you have
to deftly manage the arrow keys to quickly
escape.
The more seamless your flow, the more power
up speed you build.
Bullettoface49 impressed me with Realm of
the Mad God.
An incredible mmo I've only barely started
to play, but the game is rich and easy to
learn.
If you're looking for the easiest to learn,
CandaceK007's got what you want.
You can level up in this hilariously simplified
RPG, the famous Super Press Space to Win action
RPG.
Seriously, the space bar is the only key you
need to use for every action in the game.
Still too complicated?
Well, evo2341 suggests mouse clicking competition.
Click start and then in 10 seconds click your
mouse as many times as you can.
I tried a few times and I got up to 79,
but I'm sure you guys can do better.
But let's be serious.
Here's lulzMattR and Don't Shoot the Puppy.
Click start and then literally do nothing.
Any action you take, any move your mouse makes,
kills the puppy.
It's basically a game you win by leaving the
Internet.
If you'd prefer using your own hand as a gun,
try out Toon Crisis 2,
a great blend of live action and animation.
By carefully manipulating the focus and more,
tilt shift photography makes real life scenes
look like miniatures, like toys.
And now, thanks to ONKC123 you can add a tilt-shift
effect to any photo after you took the picture.
It works best with images that have distant
backgrounds, like these from the last IMG!
of the artist who drew pictures in the desert
by driving over dirt.
Remember the HTwins' Scale of the Universe?
Well, their new version is super enhanced.
More items, more info and even more mind-blowingness.
For instance, the entire Minecraft universe
is nearly the size of gas giant Neptune.
Negative Implode lets you upload your own
images and have an optical illusion effect
added that makes them seem to forever move
towards you.
Not trippy enough?
Make like adityaK96 and use your mouse to
fly through Barry Martin's Hopalong Orbits
Visualizer right inside your browser.
Jellotime.com
Dialectizer translates your favorite websites
into different dialects.
For instance, I can change the Vsauce channel
page to Redneck and all of a sudden, "What
is Cool?" becomes "Whut in tarnation is Right
fine?"
Oregon Trail was the first computer game I
remember playing, but it never had enough zombies.
Enter SwolfSteins' recommendation, Organ Trail.
You must choose a career in supplies and head
to safety, except instead of the wild west,
your opponent is wild brain-eating undead.
Now, if you wanna settle a dispute, use Googlefight.com.
This site lets you enter two different words
and tells you which one is the winner based
on how many Google search results they each
have.
Follow @tweetsauce on Twitter, like geniuses
everywhere, to recommend sites like NUKEMAP.
A map that lets you simulate historical nuclear
detonations and view the extent of their damage
depending on where you place them.
It's like being an evil mad scientist, so
really before pressing detonate you might
want to press The Drama Button.com first.
So there you go.
Some more things to do online now guys.
If you've ever missed a previous episode,
and there are a lot of them now, don't worry,
there's a playlist for that.
Check them out.
And as always,
thanks for watching.